your reaction first of all if you would
please to are Exclusive by Deborah
so we've known for some time that Iran
is supplying weapons to Russia and we've
seen that in the form of the Shaheen 136
drones which have featured so heavily in
the recent air attacks on Keith but I
think this is the first documentary
evidence that Iran's supporting includes
things like artillery ammunition and
although this contract is for quite a
small sum it does show that Russia is
benefiting from the support of its
relatively few friends in the world
which will include Iran and probably
also North Korea
me so we we had known about it but this
is the evidence if you will not
independently corroborated but it's
certainly looking in that direction
um who else might be doing the same
so uh Iran I think has the larger
relationship we know there have been
attempts to supply weapons from North
Korea and the big question has always
been what does China do to support
Russia because that would be absolutely
game changing if China connected its
stock of weapons to Russia's front line
there's no sign of that happening Beyond
some perhaps small bits of Technology
but but that would be the game changer
that would really make a difference in a
way that Iranian support generally will
not
what impact does support from Iran have
on Russia's ability to take part in this
war
well during the course of this war so
far both sides have consumed a vast
amount of the ammunition that they had
on their shelves Russia last year
probably fired about 10 years worth of
its annual production of artillery
ammunition so both sides are short this
year and you can see that in the way the
fighting is is taking place and and the
key message is because this war has
turned into a big war that's going on
for a very long time and probably has
two to three years to go I guess it does
show that either side can only win if
they are supported by their industry in
the case of Russia mobilizing its own
industry in the case of Ukraine Ukraine
can only win if the West mobilizes its
defense industry in ways that it's
talked about but has not yet really got
going on
we've been hearing Russian claims
overnight that they have seen off
attacks
um from Ukraine in the Donetsk region
what should we read into that
well first of all we should expect there
to be something of a war of words to
continue around the prospects of the
offensive and this uh description by
Russia sets out the sort of thing they
would have expected to see so roughly
two brigades attacking they've described
uh where they think it would go as the
most likely place so this single report
might just be part of the war of words
and you know it doesn't really matter
because this offensive when it really
gets going it's it's not going to be a
day's work it'll go on for some weeks
even months and it will include not just
land Warfare but war in the air and
possibly even attacks at Sea so we we
should remain a little skeptical but the
fact is whenever this counter-offensive
comes nobody really thinks it's going to
throw all the Russians out of Ukraine so
we should see this offensive as just
part of a long war that will take us to
the next stage and it should set the
scene for more strategic support to
Ukraine it's not going to achieve much
more than that how critical is it
um this much heralded offensive would in
your view
well it is critical because it's
imperative for the people of Ukraine and
the countries that are supporting
Ukraine that Ukraine proves it can win
on the battlefield so that the the the
the blood of their own people is seen to
make sense and the West senses that if
it provides more support as it intends
to right now that that will lead to
success in Ukraine and the Strategic
defeat in some way of of Russia so it's
a very important step down the road in
showing this war can be one it's not
going to win the war on its own
this Russian volunteer Corps that we're
hearing more
more about
they said that they had captured some
Russian soldiers and wanted to trade
them it doesn't look as though that has
got them very far what how should we
interpret our groups like The Russian
volunteer Corps so there appear to be
two quite small groups that operate in
southern Russia they are clearly well
connected to Ukraine in the way that
they are getting supplies of weapons and
equipment and the interesting thing is
that what they do is actually quite
small scale I mean in the case of these
prisoners I think there are held to be
two of them but but what is much more
significant is the effect they have on
the on the atmosphere on the narrative
in Russia I mean at their most extreme
they talk about inspiring a Revolution
in Russia on the scale of 1917. there is
absolutely no sign of that being
anywhere close but it's interesting that
they like to talk that way
we also hear about a group called the
Polish volunteer Corps they've been
making um counter statements uh on
Twitter saying that they've been
involved in the operation in bulgarad as
well
um
when you have these small groups how do
they help in the war effort if you will
or are they just a hindrance
now they are important and partly
because of the psychological effect they
have on this sense of security in Russia
and then there is a small practical
effect that if they conduct paramilitary
operations in Russia it means Russia has
to divert its own resources its own
soldiers and police to protect their own
people so it's designed really as
activity to unsettle Russia more
generally and to distract some resources
but but we should recognize that in
terms of its action effect on the course
of this war it'll be very small
and just to go back to where we started
as far as Deborah's report is concerned
as we said it's not yet independently
verified but it has been handed over to
the Ukrainian prime minister when he was
here in the United Kingdom for the
king's coronation also to our own
foreign secretary who is looking into
the veracity of this report you wouldn't
be surprised at the content
no no I wouldn't actually what is quite
a surprise it's only for about a million
dollars worth of uh ammunition so say
roughly 500 artillery shells at Market
rates so there isn't a great surprise
here we already know that we take a
different view to Iran on uh on Russia
and the support to the war in Ukraine
but it does provide a concrete example
if it's true of how this is actually a
you know a very uh well-structured
thoughtful business